I'm sorry Geoff Bowes I'm a lecturer in
discipline at Columbia University School
of Continuing Education and the Earth
Institute what you're about to see is a
set of three lectures on the
mathematical essentials necessary to go
through our master of science in
sustainability management program this
is the third of three sessions since it
took us a little longer last time we
will spend the first hour discussing
multivariate calculus which we didn't
get to and then we'll talk about
summation and integration and then the
last hour we'll talk about probability i
will not do statistics today i know i
had promised that to you and i'm sure
you're terribly disappointed but most of
the statistics that you will need is
covered in the primer that i distributed
over the summer and what i will do
before we get if you're taking my
economics class before we get to the
topic where you really need to know the
statistics i'll have an extra recitation
session after one of those classes to
give you a a primer on statistics so
that'll probably be 8pm to 10pm some
monday night okay so multivariate
calculus we're going to do multivariate
functions and talk about partial
differentiation which you'll see is an
analog of differentiation so let's just
jump into that remember that when we
were talking about univariate functions
then we said that we would look for the
derivative we would look for a point on
the function where the derivative of
that function
was equal to zero alternatively the
point on the function where the tangent
line to that function at that point is
horizontal and if we had a convex
function then such a point would be a
local minimum and if we have a concave
function such a point would be a local
maximum everybody recall this everybody
remember that this is the concave
function ok ok so what a multivariate
function so far we've had f of X as a
function of one variable X now suppose
we have a multivariate function sum
function that depends on two variables
you would think that most functions are
probably like that most real world
functions depend on a number of
variables for example you might think of
agricultural yield as a function of
labor input as well as fertilizer input
and maybe soil quality and irrigation or
rainfall and so on so in principle it
could be many different X variables ok
in this case the x1 and x2 variables are
B and Z and so we have yield as a
function of Labor b + Z fertilizer input
for a variable of two functions you can
display it on a three dimensional graph
just like for a function sorry I think I
switch that round right for a function
of two variables you can display the
graph of that function on a
three-dimensional Cartesian surface just
like for a one variable function we
displayed the graph on a two-dimensional
asian plane this is yield as a function
of labor input and fertilizer so I've
got fertilizer on this axis and labor on
that axis with yield going up vertically
you can't really read the labor there
too well so if you think about this
surface it looks like a hill that starts
out at zero where labor input is zero
and fertilizer input is 0 so yield is
zero the units of yield would be in
terms of bushels of corn and so on
whistles of corn per acre yes since we
haven't included land in this okay and
then as you increase labor while keeping
if you were to increased labor while
keeping fertilizer zero in essence you
would have very little output but if you
were to increase labor and fertilizer so
if you were to move out this way then
you can see yield is going to rise
sharply till it'll reach some maximum
beyond which adding more fertilizer and
labor that is going out this way will
actually reduce yield okay so clearly so
11 use of this function might be simply
to ask for a certain number of units of
fertilizer and labor what's the yield
right and you would simply plug that in
so let's say if you wanted two units of
Labor and three
it's a fertilizer you'd plug in 2 for B
and 3 4 z and work out what why would be
and that's what we've done here and you
can satisfy yourself later that the
answer would be 30 okay an interesting
question might be suppose that you fix
one of the inputs only how would the
yield very as you varied the other input
so you hold constant one input and you
ask how would yield very as you vary the
other input okay and in this case we say
let's suppose we hold constant labor
units at two okay so we're not going to
we're only going to put in two units of
labor so the two a lot the labor is
along this axis so you look for the
value of two along that axis let's say
that that's over here holding labor
constant at two means that you're
looking for a cross section of this
surface that goes along this line okay
with be equal to 2 and it could if
you're looking for a cross section it's
going to look you will be able to
display it on a two-dimensional surface
where we have fertilizer on one axis
yield on the other okay and in fact the
way we're going to write this is this is
yield given this line here indicates
given or conditional on labor input
equal to two okay and I would take a
cross section of that hill and it would
look something like this okay everybody
clear okay so this function tells me how
yield would vary as fertilizer input
berries holding constant labor input and
if you wanted to know what was the
functional form of that of this equation
here of this function here you would
simply plug in the value to into that
equation which is what we've done here
and you'll get 18 + 10 z 2 z squared
okay so let's do an example you may come
across this example in one of your
classes on energy efficiency or
sustainable building design suppose you
have a building with very simple
dimensions a length a width and a height
so we have a rectangular building and we
given the dimensions of that building so
length x width height width y + height
it should be zed right it doesn't i
think i made it i didn't i cropped
something when i pulled that
shirin so that said I have here a table
which tells me the rate of heat loss for
each of the each of the sides of the
building as a function of the dimension
so this is the heat loss per square foot
obviously the roof has the highest heat
loss as does the north side so this is
obviously a building in the northern
hemisphere if you were in Australia
you'd switch them around or you switch
that and that Iran and this is the area
of each of those sides so the total heat
loss is given by this function so 10
times XY is the heat loss from the roof
plus eight x y z is the heat loss from
the east side and so on ok everybody
with me when you simplify this
expression out you'll get this which is
a function of XY YZ + XZ and you can ask
well for particular values of x y&z what
is the rate of heat loss and so if X
were equal to 100 + y was equal to 70
and Zed we're equal to 50 what's the
heat loss rate and this would be in
terms it might be two hundred one
thousand firms per hour let's see okay
so that's simple enough we're going to
talk in a moment about trying to
minimize that objective function
minimize heat loss before we jump to
that let's talk about level curves okay
level curves you've all met before I'm
sure anybody know of a level curve that
they are used to seeing
okay so you probably have not heard the
term level curve before but a level
curve is a locus or a set of points
which have the same characteristic
either on a Cartesian plane or on some
other projection and one of the level
curves that I'm sure you've met our
contours altitude contours right so if
you look on a map you'll find lines
which connect different points on a
geography which are of the same height
the same altitude right those are level
curves you've probably all seen weather
maps with lines that connect different
points that have the same temperature or
points that have the same average
precipitation or points that have the
same pressure okay those are all level
curves now mathematically you could
think of a level curve for a three
dimensional function for three
dimensional graph meaning a function of
two dimensions as all the combinations
of x1 and x2 that is all the
combinations of the input variables
which give you the same output okay so
let's go back to our fertilizer and
labor to yield function this is a hill
if you were to draw a map of this hill
looking down from above what would it
look like
so you're looking down from above okay
you're looking down from above so you're
going to see fertilizer on one axis and
labor on the other axis right concentric
circles centered on the maximum of the
function right okay so that's exactly
the same as the contour maps that you
would see and you could you could write
the equation of one of those contour
lines in the following way y as a
function of B Z is equal to some
particular constant okay that is if I
were to look for all values of B and z
such that the yield is equal to let's
say 30 which is that value there so I'd
be lopping it off right there then I'd
find a set of combinations of b & z such
that yield is 40 okay so i could solve i
could solve the equation for this level
curve but just by setting this value
equal to 30 and then i have a then i've
defined my locus now everybody does
anyone remember implicit differentiation
from last time yes that cross-section no
this is not a level curve that's the
level curve that is holding the output
constant this is simply
this usually referred to as a cross
section yep okay okay we'll talk about
implicit differentiation in a second so
for a fixed number see the graph of this
equation f as a function of XY equal to
c is called a level curve of height see
okay that's exactly what we did up here
okay for example isotherms which we just
talked about this line connects every
combination of x and y so in this
projection combinations of x and y
translate into what well what water x
and y in this conceptual projection
latitude coordinates right latitude and
longitude so if i go this way I'm
changing longitude if I go that way i'm
changing latitude and these are just
combinations of longitude and latitude
which have the same temperature at a
particular point in time so you would
think of if i were to draw if i were to
draw draw a three-dimensional
representation of this map it would look
like a you know i'd have the map of the
u.s. laid out horizontally on the ground
with the hill starting down here and
rising up to this top here the hottest
point in the US okay everybody see that
okay so how do I get here's another
place here's another function here I've
got f as a function of x and y you
should get used to using different
letters for the different input
output variables so you notice for
example that I've used f as a function
of x1 and x2 y as a function of B and z
now I've got f as a function of x and y
so suddenly here y is an input variable
not an output variable okay so you need
to look at the context of the problem to
determine what an input variable and
what's an output variable this is the
function it is x squared plus y squared
when you draw level curves of this
function they'll just be concentric
circles around the origin okay okay a
very common type of level curve that
you'll see in economic analysis our ISO
quants okay I so recall in Greek means
equal hence isotherms our points of
equal temperature I soak wants our low
sigh of combinations of inputs in this
case labor and capital combinations of
inputs labor and capital that yield the
same quantity of output okay so this is
is the function and that's the height of
that function so here 60l
60l to the three quarters x ke to the
quarter is a production function it
gives you it gives you the output in
units of output for the level of labor
and capital that you that enters the
production process this is a very common
function used in economic analysis now
suppose that I'm looking for the level
curve of this function at height 600
well how do I do that I set that
function equal to six hundred then I
pick which input variable I want on the
x-axis and which one I want on the
y-axis the one I want on the y-axis is
the one that I solve for okay say I want
well actually I guess I did it the other
head say i want capital on the y-axis
and labor on the x-axis so I'm drawing
this is I'm looking down on the
production function from above this is a
map of all combinations of labor and
capital such that output is equal to six
hundred so I have to solve this equation
my production function set equal to six
hundred i solve that for k so i'm just
putting dividing both sides by 60 l to
the three three quarters
and then taking it to the fourth power
which is why it's 10 to the fourth power
and this to the fourth power so I get a
level curve that looks like this and the
equation for this curve is 10,000 over L
cubed okay so there will be times when
you have to when you know the production
function of some technological process
and you have to solve for the level
curve at a particular quantity of output
or you may not know the the
technological process and you may simply
observe these econometric relationships
in the data and you may be trying to
estimate the production function okay
and so they will be related in this way
and here is the graph i just drew